if you smell
what the shirts is cooking
what is up everyone my name is leah
shakkeever aka the shirt and i'm
europe's number one female competitive
eater and
ten times guinness world record title
holder
today i am going to be taking part in
this epic
10 000 calorie cheat day challenge
inspired
by dwayne the rock johnson's famous
cheat day food so in front of me here
i've got
two peters one hawaiian and one
pepperoni i've also
got two double bacon cheeseburgers
two fries a wall of blondies
and a stack of pancakes with maple syrup
and to top this off i think we're going
to do
the classic rock cheat day edition
[Applause]
whipped cream 10 000 calories 45 minutes
i'm hungry
let's eat in three
two one
hmm i wasn't expecting that to be so
messy
some of my favorite ever challenges are
burger challenges
um nothing beats pepperoni
have a blunder
one pancake
let's get into the second burger huge
do this pizza when pizza gets cold it's
so hard to eat
you'll see me going between sweet and
savoury a lot when you switch up the
flavors
it kind of keeps it fresh for your body
so if you're feeling any kind of slowing
down or flavor fatigue it helps you get
on top of that
oh this is tough really tough oh
[Applause]
when i find myself struggling like i'm
at my limit
i will start making things look smaller
and psychologically it kind of resets me
a little bit
not loads but seems to work 20 minutes
to go
i'm feeling positive and excited to eat
this blondie
really struggling now it's so many dense
carbs i just feel like
wow it's hit me
let's uh
okay
this is so much food
[Music]
three blondies to go i am to here
so i feel
like full of hair
[Music]
[Music]
so
done done with the 10 000 calorie
challenge
inspired by dwayne the rock johnson
in 35 minutes and 50 seconds
i feel like i'm done
i feel done thank you guys so much for
watching i hope you all enjoyed this
10 000 calorie cheat day challenge
i i need a nap
[Applause]
[Music]
you